who first doctor got a little mercenary
there for a bit didn't he
[Applause]
[Music]
dinosaurs on us spaceship over dude
Doctor Who continues as we move our way
through series seven and we arrive at
the Chris Chibnall penned dinosaurs on a
spaceship I think it's fun it's
ridiculous it's kind of silly fluff but
it's called dinosaurs on a spaceship
like the title kind of tells you
everything you need to know about the
mindset to be coming into this with and
I honest-to-goodness like at the
rollicking adventure feel of it I like
that he has never TD tag me along I love
the dynamic that he has with this great
white hunter who thinks he's so amazing
but is clearly just a footnote in in
history in general but I love that he
has an established relationship with the
doctor and he'll just gather these folks
up for a little adventure I like the
idea of the arc for the Silurians I like
dinosaurs being on a spaceship
I like Rory's dad first of all I like
that actor and second of all it just
explains a lot about Rory from the
get-go I mean it's a guy who's got a
spade in his pocket sorry a foldable
Spain in his pocket because why wouldn't
you I love the robots the bickering
robots it's so Douglas Adams I just I
love it I love it too absolute death
these snarky kind semi incompetent very
just very human behaving robots but like
only in the way that they speak
everything about I like that they can
speak and interact in
human fashion but are still these big
clunky things moving around because
usually when you get into things like oh
it's a machine but it behaves so human
they also make it look very human you
know you get data you get things like
the movie ex machina and things like
that but like to have something behave
so human but look like that I love that
I've always loved that kind of stuff
that tickles me I like it
um Solomon is a solid villain David
Bradley as he's channeling a little bit
of Filch and a little bit of what he
brought to Game of Thrones here he is
very good at being kind of the worst you
know you just kind of like oh you are
awful and I want something bad to happen
to you and this is just a very fun
episode I think the issues people have
with it are either they just can't get
on to the wavelength of the thing which
I mean fare as much as I sort of mocked
at the front end this whole sort of it's
called dinosaurs on the spaceship like
get with the program some people can't
if you're not into Doctor Who for a sort
of a lighter adventure feel then you
might know like this I don't usually
here for the pantomime feel of the
Christmas specials doesn't make them bad
it just means that that is something
Doctor Who occasionally does that I
don't enjoy and if that is the case for
you in this episode I can't really argue
with that with you I here's the one
major criticism that I will give the
other thing the shift to the more
maudlin and sort of darker moments from
the doctor especially in the climax they
feel misplaced because like I said it's
a silly episode called dinosaurs on a
spaceship we've got to Triceratops with
two grown men riding on it and making it
chase a golf ball for crying out loud
and we're going to have the doctor put a
guy in the situation that is going to
result in his death
and do it knowingly and not even be a
case of like the doctor set set up so
the guys own actions get him killed
I mean the doctor pretty much the doctor
didn't fire the missiles that blow him
up but that is the only degree of
separation that there is between his
actions and this guy's death it's a
pretty one-to-one and I'm not gonna say
like the doctor should never do that
well I mean the doctor should never do
that but I'm not gonna say the doctor
never does that you can never justify it
and they can like no you can and I even
kind of feel like they do to a certain
extent but it is a gear shift and it's
it's a tonal switch that doesn't flow
especially smoothly given you know that
and it's not just like oh the silliness
of dinosaurs on a spaceship we had this
assembled teaming going on an adventure
feel and now we're going off lead arc
and we're killing an innocent animal and
like why it was this the episode to pull
that in I'm not sure it was so that's my
major issue with it now when I say
that's my only complaint that doesn't
mean that the rest of it's amazing I
think that's where I need to be careful
just because like I say I enjoy pretty
much everything else that's going on
here and I do that doesn't make it the
best thing ever it just means that I
find it very entertaining it is it is a
light fluffy little episode and
especially back when dr. who did 13
episodes in the series it was okay to
have a light fluffy episode that is just
there to be fun is okay to have a
dinosaurs on a spaceship it's okay to
have a Shakespeare code yeah it's okay
to have these things that don't further
the grander story and aren't a deep dive
into characters and aren't delving into
heavy themes but they're just a fun time
the larger there's another one that's
okay it
okay for every now and then as long as
it doesn't become the default of what
the show is it is okay for Doctor Who to
go let's just have fun for 45 minutes
again unless it's kind of shove in some
not exceptionally fun let's have the
doctor go a bit dark stuff at the very
end I'm this one this review is running
short for me I'm not sure I've got too
much else to really say about this
though I find it light
I find it entertaining I find the
dynamics between the characters both
regular and supporting are all great
they're terrific I like I think the
villain is effective with the story that
he's in I love the robots I mean the
effects are cheesy but I mean it's a
it's a British TV show budget it's not
Jurassic Park it was never gonna look
that great so like I'll give it a pass
for that and I think you know one thing
I will say is there is it does feel like
a little bit of a waste on the idea of
the Silurians having an arc that all the
Silurians on it are dead I mean there's
a reason for it it streamlines the
circumstances a little bit plus it gives
the doctor a reason to really not be
okay with with Solomon but I feel like I
would have I would have been interested
to see a story at some point about the
side lorian's having established
themselves on another planet so that we
could have somewhere it's up again I
wouldn't wanted to become the norm but
so we could have a Sylar n story where
them butting heads with the human race
wasn't what was going on because if
you're gonna do a Silurian story not
just a story on which cellular uns
appear but an actual cellaring story
that is basically the only plot there is
to do with them
they want the planet back because they
were here first humanity's here now
clash and the only way to avoid that is
to get them off world and this sets up
that they could do that
but then it doesn't because like I said
they're all dead I can't remember now if
they made any mention of there being
more than one arc I suppose that would
be the one way they could get around
that but that's a nitpick that's
honestly honest to god
that's me feeling time trying to get
this up to ten minutes it's it is a
light fluffy little adventure story and
that's all it's trying to be and I think
it accomplishes it pretty well dinosaurs
on a spaceship have Yuri watched it
lately what'd you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it usual stuff I have a
patreon if you want to support me on
there it's immensely appreciated but
even if you're not able to you can still
like subscribe share this video around
and all that sort of stuff or none of it
if you really don't want to because end
of the day you're the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]